bend your knees a little bit wait hold
it don't swing yet
oh god ouch
jason derulo recently got a golf lesson
from will smith
and the whole thing took a totally
cringe-worthy turn
you can put some ice on that yeah like
jason
seemingly knocked out will's pearly
whites
you just can't unsee that here's what
went down
on sunday the 30 year old singer hit up
tick-tock to share a video of will
helping him up his golf game and well
the result wasn't pretty wait hold it
don't swing yet
oh god yeah will took the club
straight to the kisser why are you
filming man
so what you do with golf you put your
swing on camera and then you look at it
set it up we're gonna get your swing
right so set it up you gotta set it
right to the ball
bend your knees a little bit wait hold
it don't swing yet
oh
oh you god put some ice on that you just
can't erase the image of a toothless
swillsmith
all right you know it's my turn my turn
no i'm gonna be back
no i only need one swing i only need one
swing let me get my driver
hold up hold up
ah we can just talk about this
jason captioned the clip i don't like
this game
and we'll share the video too joking in
the caption
and we never saw jason derulo again
jason's response i know a good dentist
text me back and that is what we call
a burn folks having a good time out here
but it looks like all's well that ends
well the 51 year old actor shared
this pic of his newly chipped teeth on
instagram
writing i gotta stop inviting jason
derulo over
and jason he chimed in in the comments
saying will was
embracing his new smile i think it's
amazing
amazing look so it's not totally clear
if this was a prank or if this was real
but we do know jason has had some
interesting dental debacles on tick-tock
in the past
back in may he seemingly chipped his own
teeth in another viral video
when he attempted to eat corn on the cob
off of
a power drill
jason posted a follow-up tick-tock hours
later and he covered his mouth while he
talked about the damage
safari how much do you think it's gonna
cost to fix you don't have to fix it
it's fine
stop it stop lying i know it's
nothing look at me
but then he posted this tick tock
smiling right at the camera with a full
set of pearly whites
so real fake you be the judge
wait hold it don't swing yet oh god
oh you um put some ice on that and this
is exactly why jason has
31 million followers on tick tock and
over 6 million
on instagram he keeps us guessing yeah
that and those six pack abs
thank you yeah yeah in november jason
went viral for posting a pic of himself
in a swimsuit that put his
um man business on full display
just a little sometime the pick was
removed by instagram
for violating its community guidelines
so
he fought back and posted the image
again this time
censoring it with a strategically placed
footlong subway sandwich i wish i was
kidding
i knew it was a it was a thirst trap
picture but i didn't i didn't think when
i posted it that was gonna be my most
liked photo
in that first couple of hours you know
what i'm saying i didn't think it was
gonna like
um be you know taken down from the gram
i didn't think it was gonna
like cause this much stirrup